okay so with the release of batman and
buried on spotify i was asked to look
back over dc's long and rich history and
discuss one of my favorite scenes
involving their plethora of characters
when talking about moments that blew me
away one of the first things that came
to mind is the scene in which we get a
full origin story for cyborg and zack
snyder's justice league it's masterfully
done and for me it was one of the
standout moments in the movie just in
the same way that snyder managed to
introduce dr manhattan and watchmen
perfectly this scene gave us a complete
rundown of everything that the character
stood for not only did it go over the
death of his mother but it also
showcased the strain of his relationship
with his father his powers and a lot
more now with dr manhattan he watched
his relationship develop with janie
slater before it eventually fell apart
you learn about the character's
detachment from humanity over the course
of this scene but with cyborg snyder did
the opposite he showed us the characters
humanity and how he was a hero in more
ways than just hitting bad guys as the
character helped a struggling waitress
who was living paycheck to paycheck
we're gonna be breaking it all down in
just a bit but first if you could just
give me 80 seconds of your time to talk
about our sponsors batman and buried now
at the channel we love dc that's why
we've teamed up with batman and buried a
new podcast audio series to keep you
warm on those cold dark nights batman
and buried is a new show streaming
exclusively on spotify that takes the
cape crusader to a lot of unexplored
territory that you can listen to any
time of day until the nightfall whether
you've had your billfinger on the pulse
since he was first created or you're
going through a rebirth with the
character this is an amazing story for
newcomers and old fans who want to get
to know a lot more about the character
the 10 episodes offer a fresh take on
gotham's most famous hero and though
pretty much every iteration so far has
painted bruce the billionaire out in
quite a lot of detail here we see a
different side of him in him buried
bruce is an ordinary citizen and we've
got to work together with the world's
greatest detective to get to the bottom
of his mental and physical imprisonment
gonna stop there with the spoilers as i
want you to enjoy it as much as i am but
i definitely recommend that you go check
it out right now the link is in the
description along with a poll that's a
bit of fun for batman fans out there
riddle me this according to dc comics
encyclopedia how tall is batman make
sure you go answer and don't forget to
check out the show which is streaming on
spotify right now gonna disappear like
batman so
what's that over there look over there
i'm gone i'm gone okay so the release of
zack snyder's justice league felt like
the culmination of a redemption story
that was years in the making after the
release of 2017's justice league a fan
movement rallied behind the original
version of the film in an attempt to get
snyder's true vision released the
four-hour epic dropped in 2021 and it
very much felt like a tale of redemption
both on and off screen not only was
there snyder who finally got his work
shown to the masses but also ray fisher
who received somewhat validation after
his part was massively cut down for the
theatrical release in 2017. i've always
been a big fan of cyborg and i find the
inner turmoil that he deals with
absolutely fascinating not knowing
whether he's more machine than man has
led to lots of conflicts in the comics
and in the new 52 we even had an arc
where a sentient virus called grid came
forth from him ushering in a major
villain for the forever evil storyline
however what we got in the theatrical
cut was a pretty neutered version of the
character that did very little in the
movie beyond connecting with the
motherbox and spouting catchphrases
fishy talked openly about his treatment
in the final cut and the release of zack
snyder's justice league very much
showcased how talented of an actor he
was along with how integral cyborg was
to the storyline from someone who is
pretty much a backbencher in the
theatrical cut snyder's version gave us
one of the most powerful members of the
team along with what i think is the true
heart of the movie torn between wanting
to have his humanity back and embracing
his more mechanical mind state we see
victor stone as the college football
star for gotham university a stellar
athlete we also learned that he hacked
the it systems in order to change the
grades for a struggling student we catch
his mother arguing with the dean that
his friend had no chance of passing her
classes due to her home life and that
it's actually victor who helped her when
the school wouldn't in the midst of this
we cut back and forth to a football game
shot and snyder's signature sped up in
slow motion style just adding to the
scene so much i know snyder gets ragged
on a lot for using this technique but it
makes this one of the most epic
touchdowns i've ever seen especially
with the snow drops that cover the
screen the white beaming almost
star-like beacons contrast so
beautifully against the black and yellow
kit that stone wears and there's a real
pop to the image especially on the 4k
hdr version it's a big moment watching
stone score the touchdown that wins the
game and we cut to his mother in the
stands cheering however this celebration
is quickly cut short when we see that
his father's seat is empty silas and
victor very much have a complicated
relationship which we learn about in the
movie and we discover that he was never
really there for his son instead
focusing on his work the things that
meant the most to victor weren't really
that important to silas and this is
followed by a devastating car crash in
which he loses his mother and gets put
in critical condition told by doctors
that his son won't survive silas makes a
desperate attempt to save his life and
he turns to a signs he doesn't fully
understand now joe morton has dabbled
with this kind of technology before and
it's inspired casting to bring him into
this film when he started miles dyson
and terminator 2. really nice little
easter egg there and silas ends up
fusing his son with a mother box which
resurrects him victor absolutely hates
this change and it's clear that early on
he feels like it's a curse that he can't
escape from there are languages in his
head that he doesn't understand a
constant buzzing and connections to
almost every electronic device on earth
it really makes you question what you
would do if the person you loved was at
that store and i love how there's this
duality in the scene you have silas who
did whatever he could to try and save
his son and on the opposite side of this
you get victor who very much doesn't
want to be alive like this towards the
end of the film he's even tempted with
being with his family once more and
gaining somewhat normality inside the
mother box though this is an illusion
it's something that he could have easily
have given into because that's what his
heart desired at the channel we often
talk about how in order to be a hero
that one has to sacrifice what they want
and victor making this choice at the end
brings the ark set up here full circle
now just in the same way we question
whether he would bring someone back from
the brink if it doomed them to a
half-life we also put ourselves in
victor's shoes we discover that he has
unlimited power in the world of ones and
zeroes and that almost everything is now
under his control this includes the
stock market currency weapons cars
tamagotchis bank accounts the tinder
profile and it all rests in his hands
joe morton has created skynet again and
you didn't listen you bloody didn't
listen however what makes victor
different from the ultron-esque ai is
that victor still has his humanity this
is demonstrated perfectly in the
simulation that he creates in his mind
this is very cgi heavy full of objects
like missiles stacks of cash temples
metaphors of the stock exchange to the
classic bullem bear fighting and lots of
things that make it seem like he's very
isolated from humanity however the scene
then evolves in a victor coming across
cctv footage of a woman struggling at
her job as a waitress amongst the
mountains of money we see her barely
scraping by but she still leaves money
behind for a homeless man and his dog
snyder expertly tells us her story
across a couple of clips including her
family life although it's not spelled
out she very much also represents the
mother that victor lost there's no
father figure in the kids lives and
victor probably sees some similarities
between his own childhood and the ones
that she's raising evicted from her home
victor then ends up increasing the money
in her account very much makes him
godlike choosing to influence the
fortune of those that live their lives
in a positive way and this idea of him
affecting luck is even brought across to
the new balance in her account being
reflected in a customer prize it
perfectly hammers home exactly who
cyborg is and how it's possible to be a
hero in other ways than just beating up
bad guys however even though he's
carried out this amazing deed he's still
viewed as a monster and this is very
much shown when he walks past the couple
who stand back in horror upon seeing him
no good deed goes unpunished and it's a
bittersweet way to end the moment that
shows us cyborg still has to hide who he
is it very much sets up the public
reaction to him and why he feels like a
monster inside his father silas sadly
sacrifices himself so that his son has a
way to track the mother box down and we
see victor reaching out with his hand to
stop this much like how he did when his
mother was hit by a car cyborg
definitely goes through the most losses
in the movie as both of his parents die
and he's left alone in the world without
their guidance that's why the temptation
at the end of the film is so endearing
and after flash runs back in time he's
transported inside the mother box which
is where he comes face to face with them
amongst the nightmare hellscape of a
world taken over by darkseid they
promised to make him whole again and say
that he'll never be alone but vic
responds with
and i'm not this
it finally shows acceptance for what's
happened as well as the fact that he's
found kinship amongst the rest of the
league once an outcast that was feared
he's now found self-acceptance and also
a new family to be a part of it really
brings everything full circle and makes
for some amazing character growth that
plants him as the heart of the movie to
me it's the perfect way to introduce the
character while setting up what he ends
up becoming at the end of the film and i
absolutely love this scene obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you comment below and let me know
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out project justice
league which will be linked on screen
right now it's from our friends over at
the four nerds network and it kind of
goes over the original plans for the
justice league sequels really really
nice fan made series so definitely go
head over there right after this without
the way thanks for sitting through the
video i'm paul i'll see you in the next
one take care peace